[Musique]
je suis si fier de
toi sais-tu ce qu'est un droit de naissance peter
[Musique]
quelque chose qui fait partie de toi
comme ton nom
jardiniers de la galaxie
quoi pas de fusée alors je laisse groot remplir
les papiers
donc nous allons bien nous apparaissons  être à
court de 6 963 unités je sais que nous avons clairement
besoin d'un plan
si vous voyez
laissez-moi tout ce que
nous avons cette
[musique]
pistes que
vous voulez monstre je vais vous montrer monstre
non nous nous déshabillons gardez votre pantalon
bien qu'il puisse être utilisé comme une
distraction
nous sommes tous des professionnels ici, peut-être que
nous pouvons trouver quelque chose que
vous aviez un travail plume j'ai fait exactement
ce que plus aucun coéquipier ne tue c'est qui
c'est littéralement dans votre contrat je n'ai pris
aucun engagement de ce genre
en moins de trois cycles tout serait
perdu la galaxie  on ne peut pas être sauvé non plus
rapidement on
a encore raison
non non bien sûr je
vais t'appeler je t'appellerai
[Applaudissements]
vous